- Good Morning Believe Nation!
Today's message is Hustle.
Over to you, Jennifer Lawrence.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- The interesting thing,
for me, to talk to you,
and what makes you so
fascinating is the talent
that you see on the screen.
But, at the same time, there
is a certain innocence,
and yet a certain power,
and it seems to me that,
it's both artist and also...
business.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Charlie] But, do you believe that?
- Yes.
- Am I right?
- I've worked very hard to make that.
- [Charlie] To make it just that.
- To make that true, so, thank you.
- [Charlie] That it's both that.
- Thank you.
Well because without
gaining some sort of control
over the business, I lose some
control over the creative.
Which is most important, so, I--
- [Charlie] And the more you
control over the business,
the more you can give
flower to the creative.
- Exactly.
- [Charlie] Or give wings to the creative.
- Yeah, so I used to stay out of it,
I don't care, I don't
want to, I'm an artist.
I don't need it, you know, and,
but this is my business now, and it's my,
it is important if my agent,
my agent always says I'm
his only client that ever
calls him back as soon as he,
because it's my business
and I respect my business.
- [Charlie] Your agent
says you're the only client
that calls him back to say.
- Immediately.
- [Charlie] Immediately.
- If I have a missed call, I call him,
I'm probably the only, I return emails,
I return phone calls, because--
- [Charlie] Because you want
to know what options there are?
- Yes, I've worked
really hard to build this
and I want to continue building it,
and it's my business,
my personal business.
So, I don't understand
how people do slack.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
The question of the day
today is, I'm curious:
How much are you guys hustling
in your business right now?
How much are you hustling?
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm going to join in on the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Yong Yu Liu.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really,
really, really, really
means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- Hey Believe Nation, if
you want a little more
hustle motivation stay tuned
for some special bonus clips.
- I worked for Ms. Hughes
for about eight months
and I got a weekend gig in New York.
So, I would do weekdays
at WOL in Washington
and drive up on Fridays after my shift,
which would end at 7 o'clock
and I'd be on all weekend
long over in Queens,
that's where the radio
station was located.
And then I would drive back to D.C.
And I would never even
stop at my parents house,
never had time for friends,
because everybody was kind of,
not understanding my dream,
and kind of laughing at me
or something, or trying to,
you know my friends were like
real immature and stupid,
and wanting to party and hang out,
and I'm on a path.
And my parents were very, you know,
"Ohhh, do you want something to eat?"
"What is this crazy thing
you're doing called radio?"
I would sleep in my Subaru,
they gave me a Subaru
for college graduation,
and I would sleep in my car
at every rest stop between
New York and Washington D.C.
to block out the noise
of people questioning--
- Telling you you can't do it.
- Right!
I would literally be,
I'd have a blanket, an
alarm clock, and a quilt.
And I would take a bird
bath in the bathroom.
I'd be woken up by the man
sweeping next to my Subaru,
looking at me, 'cause I'm
like the crazy, you know,
girl in the, and I had a
baby shade without a baby,
pulled the baby shade down, you know.
And that was my life for about two months
I was going back and forth.
- How'd you get an agent?
- Oh, I got to, let me tell you...
Talk about some name-dropping, right?
So, I had a friend that at the time
was good friends with
Keenen Ivory Wayans, okay.
And, I got to meet Keenen and
we became very good friends,
I ended up doing A Low Down
Dirty Shame with Keenen.
- Oh, sure yeah.
- But, I didn't have an agent.
- As Peaches.
As Peaches, right.
I didn't have an agent yet.
And I was like, you know, how am I?
I was just going through
the list of agencies,
and I was like, I got to get an agent.
And so, I literally called this one agent,
her name was Nancy Rainford.
And I said, "I'm a really good
friend of Keenen Ivory Wayans
"and he told me to call you specifically."
And she's like this
small agency, on Melrose,
but you know, she had me,
she had Michael Rapaport at the time.
- Ah wow.
- Yeah, she had Michael
Rapaport at the time, so I said,
"He told me to call you specifically."
You know so I'm runnin' this whole game,
and she was like, really?
She was like, well, why
don't you come in and see me?
So, I went in to see her,
and I put on the jazz hands, you know,
and she was like,
you know what, I like you,
I'm going to represent you.
And I'm going to tell you
she was an awesome agent,
and she had Michael Rapaport and I,
and she started my career.
- Wow.
She started my career.
And then she eventually
got out of the business.
But, she was the one that
started my whole career.
- And it was just that--
And I got in the door
because of Keenen's name.
- That attitude, too.
- That attitude.
I was like he told me you specifically.
- That's good, that's
actually a very good.
- Isn't that good, yeah.
- That is actually something.
That's great, that's great,
I love that.
- Yeah, I did, I did.
Look, if it's not one
thing Baltimore taught me,
it definitely taught me how
to hustle, I'll tell you that.
- You know people talk about
how you need a vacation
or something, I don't,
a vacation from what?
I love my life.
I feel, I'm healthy, thank God.
And, you know I have
these incredible directors
that are interested in working with me,
and I'm going to jump at that,
as long as there's enough time to prep
and I feel like I can add to it,
you know, yeah, yeah for sure.
- [Interviewer] Has it changed in terms,
I guess there's a point
where you don't have
to chase quite as hard?
- You know it depends on the project.
I still would say, I wrote
an email to a director
about six months ago about a project
that I just felt so connected
to and never got a response.
- [Interviewer] That's surprising.
- Yeah, but you know, you
never, you know, it's yeah.
- [Interviewer] You'd just
think that professional courtesy
would be enough to--
- Oh, not in this business.
- From start to finish it
takes about nine months to,
sometimes longer, sometimes
you know, 10 months.
It's roughly a year between the time
that the story is pitched
to the time that it gets on the air.
It takes roughly a year to do it.
And it's, you know, no
one has ever figured out
a quicker way to do hand-drawn
animation in prime time,
and it's all still hand-drawn.
It's colored with computers,
but every single frame
is still done by hand.
You know this season is a little
smoother than last season.
And last season was little
smoother than the one before,
so it's, it gets incrementally easier.
It's still in many ways
a seven day a week job
to get this thing done, I mean it's,
it's a virtually impossible thing to do
a prime time animated series, yet somehow,
there's a bunch of people that do it.
I, I...
You know,
it's, it's...
I don't know how The Simpson's does it
for as long a they've
been doing it, but it's a,
it's just a very, very
intense process that just
in many ways, gets easier
when you get canceled.